it's a pleasure to be here in this
wonderful conference for the first time
hope they come here next time so I
changed slightly the title because it's
deep learning is really a catchword at
the moment but it's being somehow
misused because it's a sometimes you
call it deep learning two things that
are not really deep learning which it
has some relationship with no network so
it's it's it's to be more to the point I
think it's a knowledge involving in
knowledge graph and the text is more
precise than just putting their buzzword
so which work is a data scientist for
the day I and certified medical and the
goal we have to shift it to analyze
dictions of tests in order to extract
knowledge and it's not that easy admit
looks because as you may well know
knowledge extraction from text will be
maybe the hardest and the longest tasks
of artificial intelligence since the 50s
up to now it's being struggling how to
understand text out to understand
language the meaning of communication
between two individuals is not it might
look very appealing which is very very
very hard and this is not yet solved so
deeply for some reason some words are in
cut but this is rescued Oh together with
deep learning so that this is a summary
of my talk I will go a little bit
briefly why machine struggle to
understand text the challenge in this
Cove acknowledged in text deep learning
for the rescue and words as distributed
director is very powerful and recent
techniques that allow us to understand
the semantics of text and then combining
text with knowledge graph to represent
new acknowledged on the on the corpus
that we have so
this is really big challenge this idea
of being able to condense all the
technology that we have available since
the dawn of humanity into a very simple
and easy credible interface where you
can do any kind of open questions that
you may think of there is some big
players be trying to do this like buffum
ralpherz very well-known name google and
more recently IBM Watson they are being
successful to some kind actually both
one off was quite cool i like to play
with it a lot as I'm a physicist and I
like to play with the numbers of it and
try to discover new relationships is
very cool but the problem is still not
solved because most of this especially
specifically bow from Alfred relies on
annotated data and data test curated by
humans is not completely automated so we
still have to have a human on the other
side of the of the the line in order to
make sure that the information is
correct there are some tricks in between
that can control that but essentially
it's created data so in our case will be
we are very very happy that we if you
could have an a technique that will
allow us to dive through all the
scientific publications in biomedical
area and being able to condense this
information into a very big and complex
map that will allow us to make queries
like what will be the proteins that they
interact with each gene or this chemical
in this specific of cell that may lead
to a treatment of a specific disease
this is mainly looks very appealing but
it's really very challenging and I will
give you a glimpse of how this can be
tackled so then the traditional way of
doing NLP natural language processing is
by the well-established parsing schemes
where we
decompose a sentence into a several-year
article layers like gnomes and the verbs
and the places and this is basically
done which Bay we extract these features
this is the handcrafted pictures that
expect us on the center's using the
well-known stand for parser for instance
and then based on these pictures we can
apply a standard Plaza file Atlas vm is
a very traditional way of doing NLP in
order to make your classification or for
everyone to do it Ephixa that are
extracted from text so this is a
traditional way of doing it the problem
is that these systems are fragile fajr
in the sense that they treat each word
independent of the others so that it as
atomistic way and the way human think
about words is not like that that that
way is not atomistic we make
relationships between concepts we work
at a semantic level words are just
symbols that we create to communicate
our ideas in a common ground of
knowledge but the this is something that
is not so much useful when we want to
enter into the semantic area and want to
get really deeper meaning about the
words and how they are related each
other so yet it's it's really it's
really hard to do to analyze text with
the machines to understand the verbs how
the verbs act or nouns and it's truly
it's really a nightmare especially when
you have nested structures and very long
phrases as well as I will show you in
biomedical literature is very common
it's really really hard I mean it's it's
even myself as for you human central is
hard to understand what these guys are
staying about something happening in the
in the in the study so and other
channels like negations that you have
words but then there are something that
ties negating the real
in ships to capture that relationship
permission by the machine is really hard
so there comes the deep learning thing
and the deep learning thing is very
appealing for some reason for several
reasons it's basically the idea is
basically to represent your very sparse
data into a compressed and distributed
way so instead of using instead of using
a domestic words you use distributed
representations and we create the
so-called manifold where we lie all the
relationship between words into a very
low dimensional state to be more to be
more specific the idea is to really
transform this I dimension of the space
like if you have if we are for instance
a vocabulary of 1 million words that is
very common find in literature you
instead of using 1 million dimensions of
you 1,000,000 use a much lower dimension
by compressing it into embeddings and
then you work on these embeddings
instead of working with initial data set
so the this is the idea of the planning
is like to come you can see it as a as a
way to compress your data into
meaningful maps we test a liar
low-dimensional tea that has latent
models where you go from one layer to
another layer as in the previous speaker
as mentioned for the image case and
where each layer captures some features
of the data that are at increasing
complexity and so you can decompose your
initial data into a set of components
that when you combine them together you
can reproduce their generative models
you can reproduce your initial state of
data so you can see this is very
powerful representation for linguistics
is the same trick being applying here so
we started working with domestic way
orkut is a as a contested way so
this is the case for for instance the
vector for the wait traditional way to
represent what words if you have a word
in the sentence you put a one if you
don't have the word you put a zero and
that's the way you have to compress your
document by this representation so if
you have it's very typically we have
very large dictionaries so we have to
have a big big initial vector and if you
want to compare for instance two words
like motel and auto they are completely
different the doorknob cannot ever way
to compare these words you can do
because for the machine they are
different so the input vector is
completely different so distributed
representation are more powerful because
they get valley father they get meaning
from the relationship that each word as
in this context so it doesn't look the
word individually it looks for a window
of context and tries to find a
representation that is meaningful into
this context so we we started using just
the just this world is somehow create
embedding where from one point for
instance in this case if you put this
image is an easier to understand the
image that in words if you put this
image to a machine each image may look
very different from each other okay so
how you compare this expression with
this expression its itching image is
composed by a very large number of
pixels and it's very hard for the
machine to make comparison may be this
emotional state is really close to that
one or that one but how close they are
looking at the pixel level is very hard
to understand that but the idea is that
this high dimensional data the brain the
way the brain Lucas it is not really
expect a pixel level but there's a
so-called embedded low dimension of the
level or the manifold level where it's
much much easier if you compress this
image to this low dimensional very
complex manifold doesn't matter our
complexities the idea is that you can
you can navigate through this manifold
and you can
pear for instance emotions you can
compare and project each state which
it's emotion in this manifold and this
if you if you go from sadness to a penis
you just have to go through this line
and in manifold without taking again for
all the different pixels being being
scattered so that's the idea so that's a
trick the trick that the brain does that
we think the binders in order to analyze
very complex data into a very low
dimensional manifold so all that it
applies for the case of words engage
words there's a recent paper of a knock
off that proposed the skip Graham
algorithm that essentially it tries to
do this trick of embedding and
essentially very simple idea is you take
a word from a from a document and you
try to embed this word it was set of
dimensions in this case can be 50 off
and on and you can predict you want to
predict what will be you what will be
the words that precede and follow this
word okay so we try to use the single
world and predict the context where
these words occur okay and you you you
do this by by neural network that
somehow embeds the the word into this
low dimension of the state and so
typically the size of the window is
between 5-10 no more than that you don't
need a very large window as long as you
have a stream of words and you take this
the central world and you use the
central world to predict the these words
from the left and from the right okay
this is the idea of the stapler not
written for word embedding so this is
this works very well and sorry for that
too
okay so and the thing you can be done
with with with an arrow it works is set
you can really encode the world into
dense vectors where ET mesures latin
picture so for instance the word italy
may be encoded as a that under
dimensional vector which set a certain
number numbers so this is like each of
the numbers if you ask on the question
what this number represents what is
minus seven point 35 represents what is
nine point 42 represents you don't know
what it represents the only thing you
know is the in the context of the corpus
of data that you give to the machines
you can have some meaning with respect
to other words so Italy itself this
vector is meaningless it only means that
you can compare it with other words in
the document that's idea so you can you
can easily write this kind of instead of
you can you look at word that's vectors
so we can play around with that like
king- man plus human then we will win so
it works by analogous and it works
pretty well as long as you have a big
corpus of data to train it if you want
to play with it you can play it there's
a code the code is available on the net
what to back and then there's a some
pattern model that you can interface
sitacles and you can write your own your
own applications very easily with a few
lines of code if you want so this is a
this is the thing behind the word
embedding so you can make analogies
between between words so this case
Russia and Moscow Japan and talk it so
it works pretty well the thing is it
works well as long as you have a very
big corpus of data and it works well for
very common words if your dictionary if
is if you don't have enough data to
train it you may have some issues with
with very infrequent works words like
this is so you can take this these words
there's really a vectorial represent
vectorial representations so you can you
can make relationship between King what
is common with queen and king so it's
ungrounded Majesty second sometimes the
relationships are meaningless sometimes
the words so it's not completely under
present guarantee that it works for your
case so the Queen and yeoman is
Elizabeth catering not impregnates it's
I don't know how how it comes to this
word but sometimes it comes with a very
strange choice but to play lengthen it
there's a an online what effect
playground if you want to play with it's
like for instance this case i put oops
why is not coming it's if you just if
you google i doesn't matter if you
google is melon if you google what to
vac playground there's a website where
you can you can play with with these
relationships and there came up with
some some interesting things the thing
is that it does not solve our problem
language understanding it's only tries
to capture some semantics of the world
that's the thing about work avec so so
essentially it's a it's a you see that
for is as king and queen so if you want
from king and you put minus woman you
get pin and if you love man's magnezone
you get woman so this red error somehow
it incorporates is the gender site so it
goes from a male to female you see this
the same transformation in one vector
and the other veteran so this is very
powerful in order to work with very
large number of sorry there is something
missing here doesn't matter so that's
idea that's words of vectors so now what
can we do with it so this is if you want
to play with tears again see models that
you can really work with your with your
at home and play around with
similarities and these plus and minus
things
a lot of things you can do with gem c
library so this is some results for for
the shellings of microsoft census
complexion cell and so you can see that
skip runs and the bits all our
algorithms like even with recurrent blow
networks so it's really it's really it's
really doing a good job but this is the
the lower blink of the code you can play
with it but again we have to take some
caution because this is not really may
not be the thing you need for your desk
you really have to look at your corpus
what you're really trying to look at
your data and see if it if it is fit for
your case or not in our case it's not
fit completely i will show you why in a
minute so she just some the way to you
train the auditing basically is to
reduce the loss function that is the
expected probability of the next words
by cities on this word WK and this is
just the probability of the the words to
be to becoming the next layer given the
word and let and flatten the model that
is learned with v so it's efficient word
efficient coding of what generations
kept both local and global semantics
easy to paralyze complete to supervise
and can handle ambiguity so there are
some limitations they are basically
linear machines they found probably on
the frequent word and it cannot
incorporate external called knowledge so
there it's comes acknowledged breath the
college i think is if you mentioned here
several times in this conference is let
about you can look at the words or
concepts or as relationships between
other concepts so in this case you see
that Plato is a philosopher and it's as
a relationship being influenced by
recent does not believed in greece it
was a physicist and i'm not sure if you
are the physicist but they came to be so
i lived in Greece so the idea is that
you can you can see the the world that
you have in your vocabulary as
relationships with other words
and this can be very large in case of
there is the most non knowledge graph
it's a freebase yes like around a
million entities and billions of facts
that our relationship so it's can be
quite huge so the idea the idea is to
take this knowledge in the into the
graphs and try to try to look at it in
the in the same way as you look at what
avec s vectors so don't look at words
don't look at relationships just
something as a 10 or a binary things but
just as an embedded relationships so the
idea here is to digital work done by
borders atop the bengal the idea they
come out it's a very simple one why why
don't treat these relationships normal
service is called The Triplets that we
have a subject the relationships and the
object so for instance Plato lived in
this relationship Adams so you may treat
this triplet is called the fact as a
vector where you have the subject plus
the relationship and do add object if
this distance is small then you know
that this fact is true so you can you
can use the knowledge graph as a
supervisor layer in order to constrain
the learning so that you're embedding is
related it's your base to the
acknowledged graph that you have already
known from the curated by humans so you
can combine this relationship with the
with the with in order to extract new
knowledge show you may see this somehow
related to recommendation algorithms
where you have a certain of relationship
service you read some movie or you
were took any kind of action like you
buy a book or something and this is a
very large graph a bippity graph between
users and and the items and you've based
on this information you can extract new
information you can recommend new books
to new users or you can you can you can
make inferences based on the already
known information that you have in the
graph okay so that is the manner that is
allowed to play very very cool tricks
like this relationship between jetted
rolling influenced by so you give some
if this is the date your gift for
training the green ones okay and the
algorithm somehow tries to predict what
will be the what will be the most likely
relationship so it come out with
adultery fuse correct or not I've never
read the books of JK Rowling a reporter
but some of the others will may have
read it this make sense or not Stefan
King H I don't know so this is a train
it is it right it is your Lewis we have
to look at you have to look at the other
one so what Alexander make sense yeah it
makes sense so the other black it makes
sense the other ones maybe somehow with
voice I'm not so sure it's your
delusions it influences I mean the thing
here is that you can the nice thing
about knowledge that you can start with
a set of facts about entities and you
can expand that relationships based on
some patterns in the data ok so that's
that's the main idea ok I'm not sure how
much time I have five minutes okay I
have to speed up so so so that is
basically why why don't you use the
acknowledged graph as a starting point
for getting new relationships but at the
same time so this is another way to put
technology graph at the same time why
don't we use the text that we have in
order to
to eliminate the false positive so
somehow constrained acknowledged as is
being extracted from the knowledge graph
and so this is your rhythms that is
being it's not it's been recently
proposed for this joint embedding of
relationships the vector space based on
what Tuvok and this categorical
information that you can also extract
from the relation acknowledged okay so
this is the idea is to combine these
three elements into a single embedding
that may be much more powerful in terms
of representation of your data so this
is the algorithm is being proposed by
Chiang into it recently for Microsoft
team the idea is it's it's really simple
so this is the typical word to vary
encoding and here you have the
relationship the from the knowledge
graph basically what you are saying to
the to the algorithm is look when you
have this word I know that this world is
somehow related to other concept with
certain relationships that I know so
please make sure that the distance
between these words this is attached the
relationship and the other words that
may occur are close to zero so this
vector of think they didn't go as close
to zero as possible so the lost function
incorporates the information about
technology graph the embeddings and also
the categorical information that we have
from where these the word belongs to
which kind of hierarchy does it belongs
and the trick is really so the trainee
do either the sorry something happen it
so the colors are sized about two
million two billion facts it's a I think
is around 2 million words and two
billion facts it's used the the freebase
data set and the Wikipedia corpus so in
the results are quite quite interesting
this is for the semantics a synthetic
and so it can beat the other the other
techniques this one is the last one
for large margin this is the message of
the embeddings typically it's around
Android but it depends on the complexity
of your text and the ideas basically you
can see in this plots that it can
improve the relationship the embeddings
that it gets it from the text this is
the traditional word to vac and this is
that they are written the purple so you
see that the that the analogies are much
smoother so you can see that the way
they relate word to the context is much
it's much more powerful and recently
they come out with that the same team
come out with just come out a few days
ago with a with paper where they claim
that they beat humans in IQ tests so
just to finish them in the this is the
just to show you a glimpse of how hard
is the IQ test so in some of them I have
to confess that I filed so it's not easy
so it's like analogies classification
synonymous and Tony maws and they put
that on the mechanical turk to be
answered by several education level in
several pages individuals and the
results are quite astonished so that
this is Phi ages this is by degree this
is the algorithm this is a skip Graham
just the traditional birth defect okay
on the finishing and so that here is
that really for the first time we can
beat humans in IQ tests with this kind
of approach so just to finish so this is
some resources and firstly it's not in
the right so it's just to our case we
have plot applying this to our to our
data biomedical data is much more
complex this is just to finish just a
glimpse of an example what kind of data
do we have so this is an abstract flow
paper and you may see how hard is for a
machine to understand this relations it
is embedding this all these are proteins
these are
all these are entities just to give you
an idea we have like 25 million of
documents and this tin 25 mil of docs
you have like three million of different
entities it's very very fat ugly fat
it's very very complex but yeah it's so
it's this is kind of things we want to
solve with chemical key attach it to
target e at parting p what chemicals may
attach to target t1 at protein p1 so we
are working on that and this is a
conclusions and thank you very much for
your time questions anyone
not them aware so it the question was it
what avec was can be easy paralyzed and
see if it has some spark implementation
that other yeah that is okay and I was
not aware of it yeah there is so you
have the eraser question yeah yeah what
you have such crap today's
representation you would need to measure
its quality somehow with some metrics
can you say some words about which
manager using power measures what is
your current yeah yeah the question is
that how do we measure the quality of
the graph because the graph can be like
a false relationships are yeah that's a
good question it's in fact these
algorithms can also be helpful in terms
of detecting these spurious or non or
incorrect relationships you can if you
don't find evidence that this
relationship soccer you can look at the
probability that is these two entities
are related for this relationship and if
the party is very small maybe it's a
sign that it's a spurious relationship
so you can use the written for that as
long as the level of noise is not too
high so if we is varying claim that in
some bio medical databases there is a
lot of noise there is a lot of there's a
lot of studious relationship yeah but
that is you can use the algorithm as
long as not too high to correct his
relationship and go to the reviewer and
also another thing that week that is
being used is like putting many people's
and see if the level of agreement
between each other so typically the
level of agreement is like eighty-five
percent so you can see that even
specialist doesn't agree upon this
disease relationship so but ID is to
make the fingers as much as self
consistent as possible so yeah but you
always have this kind of thing the thing
we are most worried about is the false
positives because it's I mean it's it's
a it's not that I mean you don't want
to do bleed the scientists to Iraq wrong
hint you don't you have to make sure
that this hint we are giving to them is
reasonable so we want to have a high
precision as possible and not giving too
many false positives yeah I'm sorry
atomic representation yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's a it depends the question is
that if the the the two mystical
representation of words that I claim
that is not powerful enough than the
this is embedding representation is more
powerful if I have saved some evidence
of that I mean to answer this question
is that we don't have mean it's depend
of the task you are trying to achieve in
our case we don't try to understand
language it's not our task at all for
that task maybe the traditional way it's
still okay and there are other
techniques for that deal like recurrent
neural networks that till it is
understanding and language a translation
all this stuff we are not in our case
without worry with that so I will not
side it's sooo its best or worst i will
say that for our problem this seems to
be a better fit all those who are also
working with the distributional NLP
parsing things so we also have work on
that when that area to thank you just
the last question in short short
question about getting equipment yeah
you can say something quick about it not
we can take that yeah I mean yeah it's
very hard to do when just a quick quest
and then you can discuss better on there
and the break mean a biggity the way it
tells you to me which is really by
mapping I mean instead of using just
just a single representation of the
world you can represent a full cluster
of meanings and then you can adjust
these clusters of meanings to the test
yard working it it's a hard problem it's
it's
that there are small tricks that you can
play with it that that will allow us to
cook to get away as much as possible to
meet with you yeah thank you